今日はドクター始めた it 系で冒頭にもあった通り今回256個のスポンジを準備
しました
私はポン酢に無限度かも白い台でスポンジっていうのは何がすごいかっていうとみな
さんご存知の通りジュース威力そうなんですよ
ああそうなんですズボン g ば基本的にはよくあ食器やらへん剤とかで食器を洗う時
によく使われる
ですけども戻せば水を吸収するんです1つだけでもねその後そのスポンサー合体させて
巨大なスポーツを作ってみようと思いますそれ256個も固まったスポンジは私見た
ことないと思ってる
まあとりあえずまず全然とって質問ですねは水を吸収する9000力があると
まとめて巨大な大きな一つの巨大なスポンジを作るそのスポーツは今年てどれくらいの
3つは給水できるのかちょっと実験したいと思いますねちょっとしたらねもう世界を
救うかも知れ
もしね大雨が続いて自分の家の床が水だけ床下浸水になると巨大な樽ジョッキで錬磨の
蜜を吸収して助かるかもしれない
かもしれないわかんないんですけど今回はちょっとオープンだけじゃないんでスポンジ
の可能性を研究しますよ1月本 java と一つにくっつけていきましょうでは
行こうよ
あの位置は瞬間接着剤だと準備したんですけど存続つけるともったいないし
給水の表面積が少なくなると思ったので顔面テープでまとめてくっつけます接着剤が
ついちゃった麺は吸収しなくなっちゃうんで最大限の力
いないけど力を利用しだっていこうと思いますでは作っていくよね
なるべく隙間を少なくして作っていきましょう卒のポイントです
わーん t
1 t
どうですかねちょっとは全くとなる突き出しと後輩一ノ塚さあしてます完成しました後
はこれをいかにバランスを崩さずにガムテープでくっつけてるかで実があるとそこから
水が溢れちゃんでしっかりとまずきまを取っていくことが重要です ok じゃないと
思うよ
ピザさあ待って坊
南薩頭とはどういうことどういうことだっていいたい方が楽屋早速接続に入る接着剤と
違って表明が行きたいで濡れるわけじゃないので急逝してる量あまり変わらないとみ
ました
ひとまずグイッと言いますか
4キャロ5セット完了しました後は縦です例えばもうギッシギシに詰めていってもいい
と思います
ok 繰り返して大丈夫だったらクリアー待って絶対だめだわああもうダメだろて彼
ひっくり返そうからこうなっちゃうんですよね
これはいいんじゃないですかーた要点さえ止めれば
できたーーーーできました低反発マットジャンもはやどうすごい全然甘酢めちゃくちゃ
目だ共同そんな高くないです
入ってきてこちらのちょっ巨大スポンジ果たしどれくらいの水を吸収できるのか早速
実験していきましょうか
入ってけど準備ができましたポン自分の頭の上に水を入れるこういう家をつくったので
ここから水を入れていこうと思います果たして何リットルの水を吸収できるのでしょう
か
普通に入っては面白くないんで僕の予想を言います
3リットルぐらいかな食べサービス取るぐらいが限界かなと思ってるんでちょっとさん
入ってプレイず入れてみましょう
でサンリットに入れず間僕
の僕がこの本塾の下に僕の iphone 置きます保ち3 l 吸収することができ
ないようだったら僕の iphone に水が落ちて水没してしまいますドクター
初めてザク者としての僕の仮定が正しいと思いつつ今回の準備を進めております3
リットル入ると思ってるんだよちょっと水をあげていきましょう
が殺さん
まだバイブミリリットルからこれを2回入ればイース l んです
このまま
今ぜひやっていきますよ3
いません
1本目怖い怖い怖いん
大丈夫ぞ
主催バイトって
意外とイケてる感じですよこれ
ずっとからああ
tl
普通にいるんですけどあーあペアを待って待って待って待ってめちゃめちゃゲット使っ
てスポン前が悪かったのかなぁ
やけど9水のスポーツでしょこれで大丈夫なはずなんですよ
また文ですっ